[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département c'est parti
pour le sommaire football delétraz créé
par l'ancien footballeur du paris
saint-germain rail était organisée ce
samedi au vélodrome nationale 2 à saint
quentin en yvelines le tournoi caritatif
a permis de récolter des dons en faveur
des enfants et les adolescents
défavorisés brésilien les détails dans
cette édition baseball les cougars de
montigny le bretonneux vont reprendre le
championnat le 8 avril prochain
coup de projecteur sur le recrutement la
rénovation du stade jean maréchal les
ambitions du club pour cette saison à
bmx le vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines va cueillir le 31
mars du 31 mars au 1er avril manche de
la coupe du monde une compétition qui
sera un avant goût des jo de 2024 nous
recevrons dans cette émission
l'entraîneur de l'équipe de france
mickaël violent et le pilote de bmx
romain mahieu coup de projecteur à
présent sur les principaux résultats
sportifs du week-end dans le département
[Musique]
on commence donc par du football le 15e
trophée gol de letra créé par l'ancien
joueur du paris saint germain à raï
était organisée ce samedi au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le
tournoi caritatif a permis de récolter
des dons en faveur des enfants et des
adolescents défavorisés brésilien le
tout dans une ambiance festive avec la
présence des ultras du psg les anciennes
légendes du club des images signées à
nicolas landry à montage de à xavier
jaglin rail était de retour dans les
yvelines l'ancien footballeur
emblématique du psg qui habite à croissy
sur seine a été reçu à l'hôtel du
département à versailles dans le cadre
du trophée gol de letra un tournoi
caritatif organisé cette année au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
pour récolter des dons en faveur des
enfants défavorisés au brésil pour le
soutenir le département lui a remis un
chèque de dix mille euros
c est spécial pour qui on puisse
continuer voilà le travail 20 en plus
des vingt mille enfants et jeunes sont
déjà passés dont on espère continuer
dans le moment le même rythme dès qu'il
fera quelque chose on sera pas loin de
pouvoir l'aider parce qu'on on a
toujours cru en cette heure billancourt
le croit encore aujourd'hui d'alors
qu'il ait troqué ses tenues de
footballeur pour celles d'ambassadeur au
grand coeur le lendemain parfum de
brésil envahi le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines avec au
programme des spectacles de batucada et
de capoeira proposées par les clubs
locaux
ce sont ensuite les tambours du
collectif ultra du paris saint germain
qui ont investi les tribunes pour
soutenir haye les supporteurs n'ont pas
hésité à remettre un chèque de 2000 on
voit la fondation ça fait plusieurs
années qu'on va voir
l'association de rails et voilà on est
présent à chaque année et voilà c'est
important pour nous sur le terrain de
foot c'est les aficionados du psg ont pu
revoir des joueurs qui ont marqué les
travées du parc des princes comme
laurent fournier eric rabesandratana ou
bernard mendy
tout simplement parce que c'est une
bonne initiative j'ai été content que
rhymes appelle un ancien de la maison et
c'est pour une bonne cause
au travers d'un match on arrive à
récolter des fonds à rassembler aussi
beaucoup de beaucoup de personnes et
c'est vrai que ce sont bien sûr bien
c'est pas grand chose mais c'est qu'une
journée on donne de nous sur un terrain
on se retrouve également en train siècle
bauer ancien parisien disait d'anciennes
gloires cure eu du mal à terminer la
rencontre physiquement mais l'essentiel
était ailleurs pour cette quinzième
édition très près de suivre
c'est tout le but est atteint s'est
mobilisé les causes de cécité et les
partenaires les collaborateurs aussi par
l'intégration
vu le succès rencontré cette année le
trophée gol de letra hirai pourrait
revenir l'année prochaine au vélodrome
de 50 ans nuit du football encore et
toujours dans ce set 8 sports ont joué
dans le championnat r4 ce week-end
trappe s'est imposé contre ecouen
domicile ce dimanche suite à un festival
offensif les trappistes l'ont emporté 3
buts à 2 un résultat qui leur permet de
remonter à la 11e place du classement et
de prendre leur distance dans la course
pour le maintien
il compte cinq points d'avancé sur et
coin le premier relégable
prochain match pour trappe dimanche
prochain contre ozoir à l'extérieur dans
le championnat de national troyes
versailles a réalisé la bonne opération
de cette 20e journée en allant s'imposer
sur le terrain des ulis sur le score de
trois musées trois buts à zéro victoire
qui permet au promu versailles et de
reprendre la deuxième place du
classement à la différence de buts
mais les joueurs de la cité royale reste
à sept points de la première place
détenue super bobigny à sept journées de
la fin du championnat
handball coup d'arrêt pur plaisir les
hommes de victor à garrigues et se sont
inclinés 32 à 29 à domicile contre élite
val d'oise dans un match pourtant à leur
portée contre l'avant dernier du
classement
malgré cette contre-performance les
plaisirs wa promu cette saison reste
deuxième avec un excellent bilan de 10
victoires pour 5 défaites depuis
septembre cette place de dauphin leur
permettra d'accéder aux barrages
d'accession à la nationale 2 caps à
présent sur guyancourt la 6ème édition
du swing bike and run était organisée ce
dimanche après midi par le club de l'asm
bouygues entre la piscine andré pierre
viénot et les étangs de la minière plus
de 140 participants après le part à
cette compétition qui permettait de
récolter de l'argent en faveur d'une
association humanitaire des images de à
nicolas goury 400 m de natation 10 km de
vtt course le programme de cette 6e
édition du swing bike and run un
événement organisé ce dimanche 25 mars
entre la piscine andré pierre viénot et
les étangs de la minière
la formule attire cette année 140
participants moi c'est rigolo ça change
ça change de couleur on n'est pas des
gros najjar donc on n'attend rien de
très spécial de cette course ya par
contre compétition en fait qui fondée
sur renault
mike the bike and run c'est plutôt du
bike and run sol ou plutôt aquathlon
c'est-à-dire natation est consacré mais
ce principe de triathlon en piscine
c'est pas mal à la différence d'un
triathlon classique la compétition se
dispute en duo une bonne complémentarité
donc nécessaire entre les deux
coéquipiers pour faire la différence
dans l'épreuve qu'il faut pas que le
binôme s'engueulent qui s'entendent bien
il faut aussi qu'ils soient de taille à
peu près semblable parce que il y a un
vélo pour deux et puis la bonne
stratégie c'est peut-être d'étudier
aussi le la stratégie en bike and run
c'est à dire la prise des relais puisque
alternativement les deux coureurs sont
sur le vélo et court après une
quarantaine de minutes d'effort les
premiers participants passent la ligne
d'arrivée fatigué mais ça a été un peu
dur son début puis après la fois encore
plus c'est agréable on a donné ce qu'on
pouvait on est satisfait on se satisfera
tout ce qu'on a vu en tout cas une
septième édition devrait être organisée
l'année prochaine avec comme principal
objectif de battre le record de
participants de l'épreuve en 2015 200
courageux s'étaient inscrits pour le
rendez-vous au rugby à plaisir n'a pas
réussi à créer l'exploit contre le 7e
saint denis presque assurée
mathématiquement de se maintenir dans le
championnat de fédérale 2 les plaisirs
oies se sont inclinés 34 à 15 ce
dimanche dans un match sans pression les
joueurs de sébastien rockalies hagarde
leurs neuf points d'avancé sur arras qui
s'est inclinée 30 9 à 7 contre drancy
enfin a toujours en rugby le sky a
réussi à remporter de précieux points de
son déplacement à brétigny et saint
quentinois se sont imposés 22 à 19 lors
de la 17e journée du championnat honneur
une victoire qui leur permet de sortir
de la zone de relégation avec deux
petits points d'avancé sur le rc paris
15 prochain match pour le sky dimanche
prochain à domicile contre ministère
finance hameau de boxe à présent ahmed
el moussaoui originaire de la verrière
n'a pas fait de détail lors de sa
première sortie de l'année ce week-end
au palais des sports de marseille ce
samedi soir libinois cini la 28e
victoire de sa carrière contre le
hongrois gabor gorbicz dans une
confrontation en gironde
les juges l'ont tous déclarés vainqueurs
au point ce résultat permet aux boxeurs
de se maintenir
19e place mondiale dans la catégorie des
poids mi-moyens ahmed el moussaoui pour
y combattre d'ici le début de l'été du
baseball maintenant dans ce set 8 sports
la saison de première division va
reprendre le 8 avril prochain et une
équipe fait figure de favorite je veux
bien sûr parler de montigny le
bretonneux pour nous parler à du club
nous recevons sur ce plateau le coach
rodolphe le meur et le nouveau joueur de
l'équipe gabriel dr mo bonsoir
alors vous allez reprendre la
compétition le 8 avril je le disais
précédemment contre paris est ce que
vous êtes très rodolphe on est prêts on
mais on a tout mis en oeuvre encore
cette année pour la préparation qu'elle
soit physique on a un nouveau terrain et
on a fait un recrutement à la hauteur de
nos ambitions
du côté des joueurs à ce que vous êtes
prêts est ce que vous sentez prêt oui on
se sent prêt on enfants dans le
traitement aux maths ça se passe
toujours bien aux matches de préparation
l'équipe est prête donc là vous avez
fait une grosse préparation le disais
précédemment
est-ce que c'était le point sur lequel
vous pêchez peut-être dans le passé
est-ce qu'elle plus de rigueur cette
année on se donne toujours plus de
rigueur d'année en année c'est vrai que
mais la préparation
l'année dernière déjà avait été plutôt
efficace on l'a vu par là nos résultats
on a finit quand même 4e au classement
qui est pas mal pour un club qui est
remonté de division mais cette année
c'est vrai qu'on a on a
on a eu à coeur encore de de mettre
encore plus de de deux niveaux en tout
cas dans cette préparation oui en effet
parce que les objectifs aujourd'hui en
tout cas pour cette saison sont beaucoup
plus haut on va dire alors vous allez
faire un match le week-end dernier
contre sa vigne on a vu les images à
l'instant est ce que il ya une
différence entre les matches amicaux et
la compétition est-ce que ça va être
différent plus tard prochain bien sûr le
match amicaux ans épouse la préparation
et le vrai maths ça il ya toujours les
rivalités les deux équipes ont envie de
progresser dans ce championnat et nous
allons toujours entre complices et plus
d'intensité dans les matches les matchs
de préparation sont fait aussi pour nous
coach on fait des essais on bouge les
joueurs sur le terrain on voit un peu on
connaît leur position mais après c'est
dans le passage au bâton est ce que
c'est un joueur serait mieux placé en
haut comment il est efficace en tout cas
au bâton et en fonction de ça on préfet
notre préparation se passe voilée c'est
vraiment cette phase de test qui est
essentielle en tout cas la préparation
d'un championnat
le recrutement at il été conséquents
intersaison oui oui on avait remanié
votre équipe dans les profondeurs on a
on a eu la chance en tout cas d'avoir
été contactés par de nombreuses
personnes on a eu le luxe de pouvoir
j'aime pas c'est vrai que l'on n'aime
pas trop lire s'arme de délasse de
refuser certaines personnes on a pu
faire un choix
on est vraiment très sélectif et
aujourd'hui en tout cas pense avoir pris
les meilleurs dont gabriel on a quinze
minutes qui vient d'arriver aussi un
lanceur qui a une grosse expérience aux
états unis donc le recrutement est à la
hauteur de nos ambitions
c'est le meilleur recrutement l'histoire
du club aujourd'hui chaque recrutement à
différents sons des années après vous
savez c'est un peu la loterie c'est on
se dit on fait venir des gens on regarde
un peu quand même leurs statistiques les
des années précédentes et puis on a un
peu d'écho notamment des joueurs quand
gabriel qui ont déjà évolué en
championnat français mais après oui on
pense que aujourd'hui on est on a fait
un des meilleurs recrutements de depuis
le début du lac la nature du club
gabriel vous êtes le petit nouveau de
cette équipe qu'est ce qui vous a poussé
à rejoindre les cougars de montier
motoneige moi j'ai toujours cherché à
jouer en élite
dans ce championnat français et les
ambitions du club
ça m'étonne c'est trop lisons des
grosses ambitions des groupes projets
déjoués championnats européens et tout
et ça me plaît beaucoup
quels sont les objectifs cette année
pour le club je le disais précédemment
viser les premières places
vous pouvez pas trop vous cachez cette
saison avec le recrutement la place de
demi-finaliste l'année dernière en
playoffs
oui il serait pas trop vous cachez cette
année non non c'est vrai que on à
l'elysée les objectifs sont doubles
parce que on a aussi
depuis cette année donc il est permis
aux équipes de division d'avoir une
équipe réserve
enfin pour l'année prochaine au cap
d'avoir une équipe réserve dans la
division inférieure ce qui n'était pas
le cas les années précédentes
donc l'objectif il est donc d'abord pour
l'équipe première division à aller
chercher ce titre
et pourquoi pas de talent et en coupe
d'europe en tout cas c'est ce qu'on sait
ce qu'on ambitionne après il faudra
chercher
évidemment les finances les financements
nécessaires et le deuxième objectif
aussi les de faire donc évoluer l'équipe
2 pour en faire une réelle équipe
réserve c'est à dire qu'une équipe qui
va évoluer à un niveau juste en dessous
la division 1 donc l'écart en fait entre
cette ces deux équipes sera moindre par
rapport à cette année puisque l'équipe
de l équipe évoluant en championnat
régional qui est le gap en fait l'écart
en tout cas entre les deux équipes est
énorme donc une personne qui évolue dans
l'équipe 2 pour faire monter en équipe
une
c'est très compliqué en tout cas pour
passer d'un niveau régional à un niveau
élite en tout cas comme disait guy assez
assez assez assez compliqué donc là on
veut vraiment faire monter cette
deuxième équipe dans et en faire une
réelle équipe réserve pour pouvoir
justement faire évoluer nos jeunes et
quand les passeront est vendu
éventuellement en division 1 que les cas
en tout cas de des championnats
sopassure pas trop grand du côté des
gens vous y croyez à ce titre de
champion de france
gabriel oui oui on y croit vous en
parlez entre vous bien sûr sur ces sacs
l'équipe cherche c'est ça que tout le
monde vous vient à la porte d'à la
question ce qui peut également vous
permettre d'avoir un titre de champion
de france à la fin de la saison
c'est ce nouveau terrain le stade jean
maréchal a été entièrement rénové avec
un nouveau terrain que beaucoup vous
envie c'est un vrai plus pour l'équipe
et ça c'était un beau cadeau de noël
on l'a attendu c'est vrai que le
synthétique commençait vraiment à
vieillir est ce ce nouveau terrain il ay
là il a vraiment
donner une image encore plus
intéressante du club et c'est vrai qu'il
a il a permis à beaucoup de gens de
d'évoluer en tout cas et de postuler en
train de taper à notre porte pour
pouvoir jouer sur ce magnifique terrain
et on en est vraiment très fier et très
content merci à tous les deux dépassé
sur ce plateau où vous serez de
remporter le championnat à cette saison
sera évidemment là pour filmer votre
premier match de la saison contre le puc
le 8 avril prochain
une fois n'est pas coutume nous allons
parler de canoë kayak dans cette
émission pour la toute première fois le
club de trappes a organisé a dit ce
dimanche matin la deuxième manche du
challenge espoir et avenir de la région
ile de france a rendez vous qui a
regroupé sur la base nautique de l'île
des loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
une dizaine de clubs et plus de 200
jeunes de la catégorie minimes à la
catégorie junior au programme des
courses d'orientation les courses en
ligne pour les participants confirmés ou
novices
on écoute les réactions au micro de tv
78 on découvre plein de personnes et on
peut se concentrer à des meilleurs et du
moins bien pour m'amuser je vois aussi
pour gagner parce que j'ai assez bien en
avoir découpé fin des compétitions ça
permet de le voir comme on évolue au fil
du temps jeu ça permet aussi
au nouveau
aux nouveaux jeunes qui en retirant dans
des clubs d'essayer de nouveaux bateaux
comme du canoë ou de la course en ligne
ou du bateau descendre fin ils peuvent
essayer plusieurs choses
la compétition devrait être à nouveau
organiser l'année prochaine sur l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
retour sur la terre ferme à présent pour
parler à de golf la deuxième édition de
l'open tv 78 était organisée ce samedi
sur les greens du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines au parcours
qui accueillera les meilleurs joueurs de
la planète pour la ryder cup 2018 en
septembre prochain
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces images
125 joueurs se sont affrontés pour
remporter la victoire
on écoute le président de tv 60,18
laurent mazaury au micro de patrice
carmouze grande réussite beaucoup
participants et météorologie favorable
des partenaires actifs
je pense des joueurs qui ont été très
contents un golf préparer une manière
parfaite malgré des conditions
météorologiques de la semaine passée qui
était très difficile je rappelle que la
semaine dernière vous avez encore la
neige à saint quentin et là il a fait un
soleil splendide
toujours au chapitre golfe tv 78 ouvre
aujourd'hui une série de reportages pour
vous présenter l'histoire de la ryder
cup toutes les semaines une personnalité
du monde du golf vous présentera son
meilleur souvenir de la compétition
aujourd'hui la golfeuse professionnelle
alexandra bonetti qui s'entraîne
régulièrement au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous parle de
la ryder cup 2012 baptisé le miracle de
médina à regarder
[Musique]
2012 a médina aux états unis donc à
l'époque j'étais en fac américaine et
donc je les regardais avec toutes mes
coéquipières de l'équipe on était trois
européennes et tout le reste américaine
bien sûr dont on était un petit peu en
infériorité numérique mais du coup c'est
ça qui a apporté un outil côté sympa à
l'événement est donc en fait après les
deux premiers jours de double l'europe
elle était menée 2 4 points 10 à 6 et
encore le dernier double du samedi
après-midi c'était poulter avec mcelroy
et poulter avait fait mais quelque chose
de dingue avec cinq birdies sur les six
derniers trous plus tard en ryder cup
c'est vraiment un phénomène chaque année
et donc il avait accroché le 10 6 à la
fin des deux premières journées
je suppose qu'après poulter avait dû
transcender ses coéquipiers dans le
vestiaire et le lendemain du coup le
dernier jour le dimanche c'était un vrai
miracle
d'où le surnom miracle de médina données
sûrement par les européens puisque les
américains ils ont encore en travers de
la gorge imagine être battus sur leurs
terres avec temps avance et donc du coup
le dernier jour je me rappelle bien de
selon potes de justin rose l'a 15 mai de
gauche droite en descente
pour gagner le trou et au 18 rebelote
peut-être quatre mètres pour birdie de
nouveau et bien remporté sociale et
c'était km/heure qui avait permis
de gagner leur explosion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on passe maintenant l'agenda de ce
week-end
[Musique]
on commence cet agenda part du cyclisme
et plus précisément du bmx le vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines va
accueillir les premières manches de la
coupe du monde 2018 les meilleurs
pilotes de la planète venus de 25 pays
seront présents pour cet événement et
notamment les français qui seront
notamment représentés par le pilote
romain mahieu bonsoir et il est avec
nous justement ce plateau bonsoir alors
nous avons à la chance également de
recevoir un entraîneur de l'entraîneur
de l'équipe de france mickaël viol un
bon soir bonsoir
alors comment vous sentez vous à
quelques jours de l'événement plutôt
bien on s'est préparé pour cette course
c'est le premier grand rendez vous de
l'année du coup un peu tout le monde se
prépare pour cette course et toute
l'équipe est prête
chacun sait à peu près par et son côté
puis aussi en groupe on a fait un
regroupement et quelques semaines deux
cousins tout le monde se tout le monde
se sent bien on est prêt à en découdre
côté les coaches pas de pression pour
l'instant n'ont pas de pression on a
bien bossé les pilotes ont montré sur
les courses de préparation cet hiver aux
états unis qu'ils étaient prêts avec pas
mal de podiums et de victoires sur nos
derniers déplacements aux etats-unis au
mois de février comme on à dire les
athlètes se sont retrouvés au début du
mois pour préparer au mieux cette
ouverture troupe du monde est
aujourd'hui aussi bien les athlètes que
le staff on est prêt pour cette
ouverture de saison et pourquoi le
vélodrome a été a sélectionné pour
organiser cette manche de coupe du monde
fait chaque année les fédérations
peuvent postuler pour résider manche de
coupe du monde et nous avait plusieurs
temps qu'on poussait d'avoir une étape
qui reviennent en france depuis 2005 ou
2006 y en avait pas eu et on trouvait
intéressant que au lieu de se déplacer à
chaque fois dans les centres
d'entraînement nos adversaires baddou
pouvoir - les accueillir de tout chez
nous et c'est possible depuis à la
création de cette stadium de bmx
02 51 exactement aujourd'hui on a une
piste qui répondent aux normes
internationales sur laquelle voilà on
peut organiser des épreuves de coupe du
monde justement les pilotes vont
s'affronter sur une piste de 400 mètres
quelles sont les difficultés sur cette
piste les difficultés si les obstacles
c'est peut-être l'une des plus
dangereuses d'europe note
mais non c'est pas dangereux c'est que
voilà c'est un peu plus serré que les
puisqu'on a l'habitude de rouler sur ce
genre de format super cross donc c'est
des départs qui sont à huit mètres de
haut des postes qui varie entre 5 et 12
m du coup il ya des virages aussi à
apprendre les bosses et il faut juste
c'est pas qu'elle est dangereux c'est un
peu plus de technique que ce qu'on a
l'habitude de rouler les questions des
recettes due justement pour presser à
remporter la victoire
elle a une recette ouais le départ est
toujours très important on dit toujours
que c'est 80 90 % de la course
du coup ça joue là dessus on a une
première qui est assez courte après une
brusque au premier virage du coup sortir
premiers du premier virage c'est un
avantage et ce sera l'une des clés de la
course je pense aller piégeuse n'ont pas
assez de pistes sur vous un coach allait
piégeuse à la com romain le disais c'est
une piste technique
il ya beaucoup de voix des obstacles un
petit peu plus raide que ce qu'on a
l'habitude de rencontrer sur d'autres
formes
mais après un bon pilote qui gagne
ailleurs est capable de gagner à saint
quentin donc c'est un avantage pour les
français de connaître cette piste oui
c'est un avantage parce qu'on a vraiment
un avantage c'est toujours un avantage
d'une piste de bmx effet de bosses et
jamais les mêmes sur tous les circuits
donc effectivement de connaître par
coeur les bosses du circuit les virages
savoir quel angle on peut aller chercher
dans le virage avant que la roue avant
décroche
comment je peux passer aussi bas sur
cette bosse là où la limite oui c'est un
avantage
il ya quand même des incertitudes quand
même dans le bmx
même si on connaît parfaitement la piste
on peut à un moment à l'autre glissé
dans un virage se faire cogner virage et
c'est assez aléatoire on gère pas tout
en gérant se gère déjà nous mais une
part de chance voilà ils les adversaires
on est huit sur le sur le départ à
chaque fois assis ici ont signé une
chute devant nous qu'on peut pas éviter
bien on est dans la chute voilà c'est ça
arrive ces aléas de la course
c'est une compétition importante pour
l'équipe de france rendez vous c'est
toujours important la france en tout cas
chez les masculins ont terminé première
nation mondiale en 2010 est donc
effectivement avec une présence de deux
à trois pilotes dans chaque finale
internationale
donc oui on va être attendus en plus on
est chez nous donc voilà il ya de
grandes attentes de cette équipe de
france ça sera à nous de faire en sorte
de répondre du mieux possible
vous en parlait depuis longtemps avec
entre coéquipiers j'ai sept manches de
coupe du monde oui on en parle parce que
en plus moi j'ai fait on s'entraîne ici
on vit ici donc c'est un peu c'est notre
piste a noué depuis qu'on sait qu'il y
aura une course ici bas ça nous nous
aimions encore plus on a envie d'y être
et là on va gagner c'est la semaine et
on a pressé on est pressé dès ce
week-end quand on est sportif on est
forcément plus concentré quand on est à
domicile
est ce que c'est un vrai plus un vrai
plus parce que on a déjà tous les
avantages que lors des autres ont pas le
temps de roulage qu'on avait sur cette
piste où les petits détails qu'on
connaît que les apps ne connaissent pas
et qu'ils ont ils n'auront pas le temps
de connaître
du coup ça c'est tout ce qui est petit
avantage mais ça reste les mêmes
sentiments qu'on a à chaque fois que
qu'on va sur une coupe du monde même si
ça à la maison on a toujours subi
voilà ce petit truc qu'on n'a pas
ailleurs les publics peuvent faire la
différence dans ce type de compétition
sur vous oui parce que les athlètes il
aime sa 10ème se sentent que j'aime
sentir derrière eux la foule la
fédération tout le monde qui pousse
derrière eux et effectivement ça peut
leur étaient environ dix mille personnes
sur le week-end c'est ça sur le week-end
il attend attend à peu près dix mille
personnes se voient donc oui
effectivement de sentir tout le monde
autour de la piste qui veulent que vous
gagnez bah ouais ça va les aider dans
votre discours vous allez insisté sur
l'impact du public n'ont pas forcément
parce que voilà ils sont prêts dans le
sait qu'ils sont prêts donc voilà
l'objectif c'est de faire comme n'a pas
cherché à en faire plus parce qu'on est
à la maison
justement ça serait le piège de chercher
à faire mieux que d'habitude
non c'est juste faire ce qu'ils savent
faire et s'ils font ça normalement ça se
passera vous comptez raflé qu'on met
médaille
l'idéal
possible j'ai fait ce fils possible un
objectif de médailles précis l'idéal je
cachais les biens sont ça serait de
refaire la même ouverture que 2010 est
l'année d'un en 2017 on a gagné les deux
premières manches de la coupe du monde
donc si on peut regagner les deux
premières manches en 2018 on va pas s'en
priver
après chez les filles c'est pareil si on
peut rappeler maximum de médailles on va
pas s'en priver
romain vous êtes en course pour une
médaille
oui comme comme nous tous de se
concentrer non ici au centre
moi j'en ai eu l'année dernière sur une
coup de sur une manche de coupe du monde
du coup je compte bien rééditer et papa
qu'ici même sur les autres courses toute
la saison mais ce serait ce sera encore
mieux de le faire à la maison et devant
le public est vrai dans ce serait ce
serait quelque chose est bien donc oui
robin peut remporter une médaille sera
au coach dimension il fera partie fait
partie des meilleurs pilotes au monde au
même titre que une grande partie de
l'équipe de france masculine et des
étrangers donc aujourd'hui va il fait
partie des huit personnes qui peuvent
gagner une manche pour les deux merci à
tous et de dépasser sur ce plateau nos
fonds un reportage complet sur cet
événement à lundi prochain sur tv 78 je
rappelle la compétition a débuté ce
vendredi 30 mars au vélodrome nationale
2 à saint quentin en yvelines
il y aura également du handball féminin
ce week-end le club de montigny le
bretonneux reçoit ce dimanche 1er avril
à 16 heures harnes pour le compte de la
15e journée du championnat de nationale
2 lésiné monteyne mal en point avant
dernière du championnat tenteront de
valider une deuxième victoire en deux
matches ce sera une première cette
saison pour les joueuses coachée par
denys choulet
si vous voulez assister au match
l'entrée est gratuite en football on
jouera les demi-finales de la coupe des
yvelines ce dimanche à 15h dans la
première rencontre plaisir le petit
poucet de l'épreuve leader du
championnat de 2e division reçoit dans
son stade bernard jégou laisse maurepas
une équipe de première division de
district classé à la deuxième place mais
qui n'a remporté aucun match de
championnat en 2018 la rencontre
s'annonce donc électrique pour ce derby
dans le deuxième match de ces demi
finales de coupes divines but en cours
au soudan son stade maurice baquet
l'équipe d'hardricourt ce dimanche 1er
avril
les deux équipes évoluent toutes les
deux dans le championnat de première
division de district elles ne sont
séparés que par un petit pan classement
la rencontre s'annonce serré et on
termine c'est un jardin à part de la
boxe l'élan courtois adila hamouma dit à
montera sur le ring ce vendredi 30 mars
à levallois-perret évinois de 37 ans va
combattre contre naji
mohammedi pour le titre vacant wbc
continental des poids super moyens une
victoire lui permettrait de combattre
pour le titre mondial a dit là où on m'a
dit légèrement favori pour ce combat
il affiche un bilan de 23 victoires dont
16 par ko pour seulement 4 défaites et 1
nul
de son côté un hadji mohammedi affiche
39 victoires pour 5 défaites mais le
boxeur des bouches du rhône a perdu deux
de ses quatre derniers combats
qui sortira vainqueur réponses souvent
dans l'histoire c'est la fin de ce
statut de sport merci de l'avoir suivi
très belle soirée sûreté 1078
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]